After World War Two, the applications of basic
discoveries in biology took off—and became
big business.
Today, we’ll look at the rise of Big Pharma
and GMO foods.
We’ll also discuss how life-science technologies
fundamentally changed reproduction: it’s
time to invent In Vitro Fertilization and clone a sheep!
[Intro Music Plays]
When we left medicine and the brain sciences,
one had antibiotics and the other had talk
therapy—which were major developments.
But many disorders still lacked effective
treatments.
That changed during the Cold War.
Brain science took off, and several researchers
found, starting with animal models, that treating
brains with different chemicals could affect
mood and behavior.
One of the first blockbuster brain drugs was
a compound called chlorpromazine, better known
by the brand name Thorazine.
Approved for psychiatric use by the U.S. Food
and Drug Administration in 1954, Thorazine
is an antipsychotic.
It reduced the need for electroconvulsive
treatment.
More patients returned to their families.
And it’s still used today.
Another early blockbuster was meprobamate, the first of the
“minor tranquilizers”—nowadays, called
anti-anxiety medications.
Different companies marketed versions of meprobamate,
the biggest of which was Miltown.
Miltown became the bestselling drug in the
U.S.
Some historians estimate that five percent
of all Americans were on Miltown by the late
1950s.
It became normal to take tranquilizers.
There was even a Miltown Martini—the Miltini!
Kids at home (and irresponsible adults): do
not put tranquilizers in alcohol!
Tranquilizers were the first scientifically
created, advertising-promoted drugs for the
“worried well”—people who mostly functioned
in society, such as problem children and those
neurotics in talk therapy.
Then in the early 1960s, drug company Roche developed diazepam, the first
anti-anxiety drug of the benzodiazepine family.
“Bennies,” which you may know from the
brand name Valium, worked faster and longer
than Miltown.
Like Miltown, Valium affected culture.
These pills became commonplace.
You might have heard them called “mother’s
little helpers.”
This nickname tells the story of the U.S.
at the time: most women worked at home, many of them suffering
from the “problem with no name”—which we now might call Depression and Anxiety,
owed in part to a lack
of options, respect, and rights.
The new anti-anxiety pills worked to calm
worried brains—but they didn’t change
a patriarchal culture.
More openly debated at the time was the first
drug to treat mood disorders such as bipolar
disorder, lithium.
Starting around 1950, some psychiatrists called
for the naturally occurring element lithium
to be used prophylactically as a mood stabilizer—that
is, to prevent a mood disorder.
Lithium can cause serious side effects, however,
that make patients feel sluggish and out of
it—“stable” but not exactly great, depending
on the dose.
So the FDA only approved lithium for prophylactic
use in 1974.
Drugs for major depressive disorder were also
controversial.
In the 1960s, psychiatrist Joseph Schildkraut
put forward the chemical imbalance theory:
basically, since antidepressants seem to work
by elevating levels of norepinephrine and
serotonin, depression may be caused by a lack
of these critical neurotransmitters.
This theory is widely talked about, but it’s
never been proven.
Where are you, scientific method?
Still, in 1987, the antidepressant fluoxetine—marketed
as Prozac—was sold as the first selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitor, based on the
imbalance theory.
But pills were not the only ways of making
money from research on bodies.
Another was the ability of medical researchers
to turn certain samples of human tissues into
immortalized cell lines using tissue engineering.
These cells don’t die out, but keep growing
indefinitely.
Experimenting on living humans can be dangerous
and complicated.
Trying out new drugs on a dish full of human
cells is cheaper and safer.
But the cells came from a specific human,
and the new practice of immortalizing cell
lines raised thorny questions about ownership.
Help us out, ThoughtBubble.
The very first human cell line to be immortalized
has been experimented upon on every continent
and in outer space, helping thousands of researchers
develop new therapies.
And it came from someone who didn’t give
consent and received no reward.
Henrietta Lacks was an African-American housewife
in Baltimore who showed up at Johns Hopkins
in 1951 complaining of abdominal pain.
She was diagnosed with advanced cervical cancer.
As he’d done with hundreds of incurable
cancer patients before, cell biologist George
Gey took a biopsy, or tissue sample,
and tried to keep it alive, giving it the
kind of nutrients it would get from the body,
but in a machine he’d designed called a
roller drum.
Lacks’ tumor cells could keep growing, unlimited
by the size of a dish.
His idea was that, since cancer cells divide
aggressively and don’t rely on a plan from
the body, they might be easier to keep alive
forever outside of one.
Gey had tried and failed many, many times
before, so he was surprised when Lacks’
cells seemed to happily divide and divide,
never dying out.
His persistence paid off!
Gey freely shared the cells with other researchers,
and the cell line—HeLa—became
the most important cell line in biomedical
research and remains so today.
By 1954, this strain of cells was being used
by Jonas Salk to develop a polio vaccine!
And HeLa would later be used for cloning human
cells and developing in vitro fertilization.
Buuut…
Henrietta Lacks—the human, with a family
and friends and dreams and bills—was long
dead.
She had never consented to having her cells
used for research.
Her family was not aware of HeLa’s existence
until 1975.
And they didn’t receive any compensation.
Thanks, ThoughtBubble.
As historian Hannah Landecker explains, HeLa
is a particularly loaded technology.
To Gey and many scientists, it was clearly
a gift to science.
To the Lacks family, the cell line clearly
represented the historical and continuing
oppression of black women: black body parts
used by white people to make knowledge and,
in the process, make money…
Eerily reminiscent of slavery.
At least HeLa doesn't cost anything.
This is not the case with all cell lines.
In 1976, John Moore underwent treatment for
hairy cell leukemia at the UCLA Medical Center
under the supervision of Doctor David Golde.
He developed tissue from Moore’s cancer
into a cell line, Mo, that was later commercialized
for millions of dollars.
In 1990, the California Supreme Court ruled
that Moore had no right to any share of the
profits realized from the commercialization
of anything developed from his “discarded”
tissue.
The lucrative cell line is owned by the regents
of the University of California—not the
man from whose body the cells were taken.
New technologies also raised new questions
in agriculture.
You’ve probably heard of GMOs, or genetically
modified organisms.
A GMO has had its genome, or DNA blueprint,
edited to include genes from another organism.
Genetically transforming microbes took off
starting in 1973.
The first genetic engineering techniques didn’t
work with complex organisms, but new techniques
soon followed.
In 1977, a biologist named Mary-Dell Chilton
used an altered form of a common bacterium
called Agrobacterium tumafaciens to insert
genetic material from a foreign species into
a plant.
Agrobacterium works by forming a plant tumor,
called a gall, on the roots of a plant.
Chilton’s breakthrough was followed by similar
work in Belgium.
But she became—and remains—the “Queen
of Agrobacterium.”
In the 1980s, chemical companies used her
work to develop GMO crops.
In 1983, John Sanford and Edward Wolf invented
a mechanical means of genetically transforming
plants at Cornell—the gene gun.
This was also used to make GMOs.
The first approved GMO was a pest-resistant
tobacco in China, in 1992.
The same year, the U.S. approved the first
GMO to eat—a bruising-resistant tomato,
the “Flavr-Savr,” marketed under the farmy-sounding
name “MacGregor’s.”
These tomatoes contained a gene that turned
off the enzyme that breaks down pectin.
This kept them from going soft on long truck-rides
from Mexico.
In the 1990s, a company developed the super-fast-growing
AquaAdvantage salmon—the first GM animal
for food.
Canada approved it, and the FDA ruled the
salmon safe in 2015.
But the next year, they postponed AquaAdvantage’s
release “until final labeling guidelines
for informing consumers of such content are
published.”
And they’ve postponed every year since.
But the big money GMOs, which at first faced
little pushback from consumers, are grains
In 1995, Bt corn was registered with the EPA.
Farmers have used Bt, a pesticide derived
from the bacterium Bacillus thuringiensis
, since 1920.
On its own, the pesticide is considered organic!
Around the same time, Monsanto introduced
“Roundup Ready” soybeans, resistant to
their top pesticide, glyphosate.
The soybeans were followed by corn in 1998.
Each chemical company set up a vertical system,
selling GM seeds and related herbicides.
And making tons of money as farmers buy both.
GMO grains are common throughout the United
States, China, Argentina, and India, but largely
resisted in Europe.
The market for GMOs today is estimated at
over three hundred billion dollars, all from
only four crops—soy, canola, cotton, and
corn—modified with only two properties—herbicide
tolerance, insecticidal action, or both.
None of these makes foods more nutritious
or better tasting.
These properties are all about yields for
grains that are fed to animals or used as
ingredients.
So much of the recent controversy about GMOs
isn’t really about the technology of changing
plant genomes, but the why behind these changes.
Other advances in genetics technologies were
more readily accepted: assisted reproductive
technology.
In 1978, in England, Louise Brown became the
first baby born using in vitro fertilization
or IVF.
“In vitro” means “ in glass”—babies
conceived in dishes instead of wombs.
Basically, IVF and similar techniques involve
isolating gametes, or sex cells, and moving
them around in labs.
Egg donation became possible soon after, in
the 1980s.
Today, IVF, the donation of gametes, and other
forms of assisted reproductive technology
are widely accepted.
But these technologies are often expensive,
so not everyone has equal access to them.
Meanwhile, in agriculture, other cell biologists
pushed new reproductive technologies.
Dolly the sheep was born in 1996, the first
animal created using the technique somatic
cell nuclear transfer or SCNT—widely described
as “cloning.”
Dolly was created by embryologist Ian Wilmut
and others at the Roslin Institute of the
University of Edinburgh—and named after
Dolly Parton!
SCNT is surprisingly simple: somatic cells
are body cells, like from skin.
The nucleus of a somatic cell contains a DNA
blueprint.
But it’s not normally enough to make a new
organism—that requires gametes.
But with SCNT, the egg’s nucleus is sucked
out by a micropipette, and the nucleus from
a somatic cell is inserted.
This causes the egg to start dividing—to
make a baby—and means the genetic material
is from that somatic cell.
The baby is a “clone” of the somatic donor!
With new reproductive technologies, it’s
technically possible to clone a baby human,
but that’s banned in most countries.
Also, cloning wouldn’t result in an exact
copy of the single “parent,” just a child
with a similar genome.
Experience would turn certain genes on and
off: this is called epigenetics.
And environmental stimuli matter more than
genes in many cases: breathing in polluted
air, for example, is bad no matter how good
the genes related to your lungs are.
Next time—we’ll introduce the life sciences
equivalent of the atomic bomb: it’s time
for the Human Genome Project, forensic genetics,
and a new “personalized” era in biotechnology.
Crash Course History of Science is filmed
in the Dr. Cheryl C. Kinney studio in Missoula,
Montana and it’s made with the help of all
this nice people and our animation team is
Thought Cafe.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us, you can check out some of our other
channels like Scishow, Eons, and Sexplanations.
And, if you’d like to keep Crash Course
free for everybody, forever, you can support
the series at Patreon; a crowdfunding platform
that allows you to support the content you
love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued
support.